le Barbier de Séville de Beaumarchais
joué par le théâtre Fontan ka de
Saint-Pétersbourg une oeuvre française
pour une intrigue en Espagne interprétée
par des Russes une combinaison
d'étonnante
je pense que c'est un super mélange de
culture si j'aime bien ça
la seule chose qui différencie la pièce
c'est que les Français parlent beaucoup
plus vite que les Russes alors quand le
metteur en scène a abordé la pièce en
russe il était loin de penser qu'elle
serait deux fois plus longue que la
version française
c'est simplement parce que nous les
Russes nous parlons plus lentement dans
cette aventure artistique si les
comédiens sont tous russes le metteur en
scène lui est français il s'agit de
Jean-Daniel Laval directeur du théâtre
montancier à Versailles la compagnie de
Saint-Pétersbourg connaissait déjà le
théâtre versaillais pour y avoir joué
les trois sœurs de Tchekhov alors il y a
deux ans au cours de l'année de la
Russie en France Jean-Daniel Laval a
proposé de les mettre en scène dans le
Barbier de Séville
je n'imaginais pas à quel point j'allais
être proche de Jean-Daniel et son équipe
que j'apprécie beaucoup il y avait
vraiment une bonne ambiance et on s'est
beaucoup amusé et c'est ce que j'aime
dans le théâtre quand je travaille c'est
de m'amuser à 100% pour moi c'est
tranchant et cet échange c'est un cadeau
de la vie une belle aventure humaine que
la différence de langue n'a pas entraver
Jean-Daniel Laval me parle pas russe et
aucun comédien de Saint-Pétersbourg et
francophone
qui vont expliquer les choses pendant
des heures comment il perçoivent le
personnage comment l'interpréter
Jean-Daniel lui sait se faire comprendre
sans les mots seul le geste suffit pour
transmettre une idée que les comédiens
peuvent s'approprier le théâtre
fontanica de Saint-Pétersbourg jouera le
Barbier de Séville en russe la pièce
sera sur titrée en français pour le
public parmi les 8 dates de spectacles
trois lieux à retenir Paris des 21 et 22
janvier Versailles les 25 et 26 et
Fontenay-le-Fleury le 29 janvier